all right
beginning livestream and I do want to
tweet it so soon as I can get have a
link yeah I found it
oh we are alive sweet three people
watching now what's up all right boom
hello
alright yes we are alive this chat is
moving now so now there's definitely
more than three people watching cuz I
can see the chat how's it gone guys
hello hey hey that that's a thing so
I'll wait for always people to join but
basically I'll explain like what this is
what we're doing with it and the whole
wallpaper thing the whole situation
how's it going what's up what's up hi
how's gone people are joining this is
good
hello it's been about a minute so that
this you probably already know but this
we did a video about the LG wallpaper
LG what's the full name LG signature
OLED TV W W stands for wallpaper so we
call it the wallpaper TV did a whole
video about it but I never really in
that video got to show you like the well
the behind the scenes of like the whole
thing like people still ask to this day
like so how does it how exactly does it
connect to the wall because I never
showed it off the wall so that's kind of
the purpose of this livestream
basketball emoji what's up
we streaming yeah it should be pretty
good should be 1080p at least I think
it's 1080p 60 yeah we're good
you saw the snap yeah snap chatted it I
put it on the instagrams story
it's the hype is real is what I'm trying
to say there's so many warnings all over
the box to like this is the clean front
of the box with it on the side it's like
alright two people to lift this side up
like fragile
don't knock it over don't bend it don't
pinch the corners don't stab it there's
all kinds of all kinds of warnings but
yeah
okay this is I have a tape measure feel
like me as a sense of scale is pretty
good for how big the box and the TV are
but this all right this is 65 inch you
can probably see that right now I'm
gonna go BAM that's 65 inches you turn
them 65 inch diagonal ready
and now this thing is I said that the
second the only other size I linked it
below the 77 inch version so we go out
an extra 12 inches
yeah it's huge ah it's very tall it will
be taller than I am or it will be bigger
diagonally than I am tall which I
haven't seen that many nearly 80 inch
TVs what is good how much for that thing
so I linked it below
they have like a promotion pricing for
it at this point which is like I think
it's either 14 or 15 grand for this one
and then like six or seven grand for the
65 inch so it's still not a normal buy
this is definitely a dope text like
really high-end probably not gonna buy
this everyday type of thing what is good
LGB 30 review yeah that's probably gonna
happen when they give us like final
review units and a release date that's
another thing LG should think of
thinking doing soon hello from Egypt
what's up are you using a chromecast or
the built-in smart service I use both
but I do have a chromecast plugged into
it which is what you're looking at but I
will also be using the LG smart services
because they're pretty good the OS the
webOS on TVs is pretty good I'm not
gonna give away the old one says James
from the super chat mm probably not I'm
gonna probably find another home for it
either somewhere in here or in Studio B
or something like that so should we open
it up they just want to talk about it or
just want to say we're we're watching
from hello do I like pizza
yeah daily driver right now is so I've
I've said before I always carry two
phones my main SIM card is in a Galaxy
Note 8 and my iPhone SIM card is in a
gala and iPhone 8 so i funny plus in its
blush blush gold it's gold but it's like
the the color I've showed in the video
that I unboxed it's that but it's a lot
hello open it open it open it open it
open it
just say it open it sup concept creator
I'm doing well I'm excited I'm gonna
yeah I'll probably need help but I'll
just start to see how much I can get
into this I can't really see the way I
can see the framing all right let's do
it
world's longest tape cut incoming
now okay there's like a little welcome
thing on top but then on the back it's
all the instructions that we followed
last time which is how to set this up so
basically how it works in case you're
not familiar is there's these little
hooks and also a bunch of magnets so the
easiest way to explain it is like when
you you know how when you hang up a
picture frame like you hang like the
little hooks over the side and you just
hang it on the wall that's basically
what we did with this but with a much
larger frame and then there's also
magnets in this sheet of metal and you
bolt the sheet of metal to the wall and
then you hook and magnetize the TV to
the sheet of metal maybe that's I think
this is just all my cables and i/o and
stuff I'll take four please so this is
the extension cable gotta love that this
is a good cable here
it's a good cable still having Tesla
problems no I'm not having any Tesla
problems I've I feel like I get that
question like every time even though the
last few videos I've made about the car
have been pretty positive the most
common or most viewed video about it is
the one where I had problems but it's
good now
all right this box I think this is gonna
be the remote control and some cables I
would be willing to bet it is the
installation guide and some cables and
the installation guide has like a bunch
of drywall screws and metal screws cuz
you have to use them to get them in the
wall I wonder if it's heavier like a lot
heavier the actual panel
it was pretty light but you'll see it's
a different remote that's two remotes
I'm not sure this is the one we had
before the LG remote but it also comes
with a slim remote did we get this
before I remember this at all all right
here I'll show it to you what video
lighting do you suggest for tech
youtubers I suggest LEDs cuz they run
cool cool I'll get it thank you
I suggest LEDs because they run cool and
like fluorescents are hot so I don't
want them to like bake all your
electronics ever feel stuck or lost was
just too much stuff I see what you're
trying to do there but no I am NOT in
that position right now alright this is
the first remote
so fast yes the chat is moving very fast
hello from Connecticut hello can you
read the comments I try get a little mic
for screens please it's hard to hear
yeah I'll probably end up doing that
because this is a lot well here
yeah she definitely get there I can walk
around and just random clear accessories
all right cool piece of styrofoam
[Music]
[Music]
they definitely thought about this
pull this out
this is like the biggest piece of
styrofoam alright that's the sound bar
right here and I'm the panel I think I
can literally
this is a huge TV oh my gosh
yes Oklahoma City Thunder is deep did
they get weighed yet I don't think they
got weighed yet but they're still pretty
deep right now all right I'm gonna this
is literally just a huge piece of
cardboard that says LG's signature but
it's not part of the TV at all so yeah
god I can't show you how thin it is
really but this is more cardboard and
this oh this has the sheet of metal in
it well it's not that heavy we're almost
at the moment of truth guys where are
you planning to hang it I'm planning to
hang it right there I'm trying to take
this one down and replace it with this
one
oh I don't even want to touch it all
right you're looking at the back of this
I'm gonna slowly
this is insane cuz it's literally
flexing in my hands right now not
touching the screen okay so you know
that moment of truth when you take like
this screen protector off of smartphone
you like peel it back that's the
cleanest it will ever be and then it's
over this is the one the biggest version
of that put gloves on oh I should've oh
that's probably what the professional
installers do they have like white
gloves and I do this whole thing yeah
you're right I should hide gloves on but
yeah do that next so the sound bar is
still in the box right there but I'm
going to take the rest of the
and then pick it up by the back leaning
right here how's that reflection by the
way I'm doing this but there it is there
it is out the box oh my gosh yeah no
it's not a graceful in boxing at all but
it is super insane in person let me turn
this sideways real quick
does that give you an idea does that
give you an idea I keep leaving the mic
so it's kind of hard to talk how's the
latency for gaming it's actually not bad
I mean you don't want to do any serious
PC gaming on it but console gaming on it
is fine yeah yeah it's been okay look at
it watch it wobble when I move it that's
that's what was happening while I was
unboxing it and will continue to happen
until I stabilize it
all right how's the reflections it's
probably brutal right now oh man can't
see like all the lights and whatever or
should I move it down not bad all right
perfect so now yeah you get the idea
make a drop test of it who said that
that is a terrible idea why would you
put that in the super chat heard about
the Nexus 6p early battery shut off
controversy I have not heard that
everyone seems to have a conspiracy
about that every year about phones and
planned obsolescence and I got iOS 11 on
my old iPhone and it stopped working
I hear that every year all right so does
this sound for any different that's the
question because here's the theory we
have the soundbar from the current one
you can see that right yeah you can see
the soundbar from the current one
connected by that cable this in theory
uses the exact same sound bar the exact
same cable but we'll just be bigger so
we wouldn't have to install the sound
bar again but we kind of also want to do
in the future in the near future like a
really good table hiding solution
version of this Oh gonna show this the
sheet of metal how do I show this yeah
I'll just
all right so
so here's the idea behind how this goes
up on the wall
this sheet of metal I'm assuming it's
aluminum but it's really thin this is
what gets bolted to the wall this is
what you put the drywall screws in the
wall for and then this is what hooks the
TV the TV hooks into these little
circles then there's magnets throughout
this and the TV has magnets in it
and they all just connect via magnets so
that's what's behind the TV on the wall
behind me right now
this is so much more precarious than any
phone unboxing you will ever see
appreciate this being live on YouTube I
could break so many things in this video
looks about the same
it could be a little bigger but probably
doesn't have to be the only thing is the
power supply for the bigger display it
might have to be bigger
I might just replace it just to be safe
because I don't know what the insides
are sure the cable it looks dope and
futuristic well this is the cable it
connects to the back of this which you
can't see but it's behind here and then
it looks like that and I just velcro
taped it to the wall so this is a super
simple version of it
velcro taped to the wall it's a white
wall so it kind of blends in that way
but I think the ideal version of it is
cutting a little slot a little invisible
slot right behind the bottom of the TV
cable goes in there comes down and comes
out the bottom of the wall with another
slot so that's what this cables for
that's the extension but both into the
TV already is the short part of the
cable try to bend it into a curved
screen you totally could this would
easily bend into a curved screen I just
don't have a curved wall you know
looks exactly the same to me
well that is nuts that is a huge box if
everyone then moves with me $1 I can pay
tuition nice yeah I don't have a if it's
a wall so whatever the shape of the wall
is is the shape that you just put the TV
on and is good most walls are straight
so that's just how that worked out um
drop test now I'm not about to do a drop
test show how bendy it is I think I'll
show it one more time the thinness of
this panel will be very careful with it
that is the wallpaper TV
all right I guess from here it's just
the setup process we're gonna we're
gonna dig into the wall we're gonna get
into this thing thank you thank you for
I'm glad you like the live stream take
your top off someone gave two dollars
and said take your top off that's an
actual comment in the super chat what TV
stand is that oh this wow it's a great
question
where did I get it probably from was my
waiver is between these two one of
them's wafer and one of them is all
right now they're both way fair yeah
yeah they're way fair so if you go to
wayfarer waa why f AI r they have all
kinds of TV stands that are all made by
all kinds of sweet manufacturers that is
one of them get them mic to clip on your
shirt yes definitely a hot tip for this
live stream I'm glad you guys came and
saw that tip and gave it to me well it's
so fast keep live yeah we're up we're
alive
yeah you know that's like basically
about it drought where you gonna install
it we're gonna install it in the same
place the current one is basically we're
about to do is take this one down and
put the new larger sheet of metal on the
wall and then put this one up in the
same space the question is what do we do
with the old one which is like find a
place to put it
gosh it's super fast super fast Golden
State blood I can't see
you're right diamond picture isn't level
diamond picture isn't level I don't know
what that means tell a bad pun our fees
give away dress yeah people everyone
wants me to give it away but the problem
is shipping this is probably probably
literally impossible since you don't
have a job I don't keep the boxes to
these so shipping a wallpaper TV without
it breaking is unless you like pay
someone to put it in their trunk and
drive it somewhere is probably
impossible box of Cheerios
do you think the sambar is the same
but I'm so there places just to be safe
because I feel like the power supply and
it may be different and it may not be
but just to be safe the larger panel
will get the new sandbar anyone else
notice that back there anyway
yeah that's about it we took it out the
box I think if you stay tuned to Twitter
you'll see the progress we make with it
because obviously we made the whole
video on the first set up and we have
the the cable ties going and it's pretty
well cable managed but the whole idea is
we want to find some furniture or we can
we can keep a Nintendo switch plug into
it we can keep the chromecast ultra
plugged into it the Apple TV 4k will we
plug into it and the ps4 will be plugged
into it ps4 pro so that's four things
that will all be on this massive TV and
then we'll be doing some some more fun
live streams because this will be the
centerpiece to anything we do gaming
related like if I just want to play 2k
and smacks Meeks some of you guys in 2k
like that will be on this TV so the
faster and cleaner we can get it set up
the better until then that's been a
quick livestream just taking a giant
flat screen panel out the box and
sharing it with you guys but next up is
the real work which is plugging it in
stuff and hanging it on the wall so
thanks for watching this one talk to you
guys later in the next video peace